welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with this we will soon hear
testimony from a highly anticipated
witness in the impeachment inquiry who
could bring the investigation directly
to president Trump Gordon Sunland the US
ambassador to the European Union has
been linked multiple times to allege
efforts to pressure Ukraine to
investigate the Biden's this morning
he'll likely be asked about
conversations he's had with President
Trump all four witnesses who testified
yesterday expressed concern over the
president's actions in Ukraine one
National Security Council official
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
described having his quote worst fears
validated Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill Nancy what can we expect from
ambassador sunland today he's probably
our most unpredictable witness
he sure is his original story Anthony
was disputed by so many other witnesses
that he has already had to amend his
closed-door testimony and we anticipate
he'll probably tweak some things again
when he testifies publicly this morning
yesterday one of his close colleagues
said that in hindsight he wishes he had
done more to push back on what the
president wanted I now understand that
others saw the idea of investigating
possible corruption involving the
Ukrainian company Purisima as equivalent
to investigating former president Vice
President Biden former special envoy
kurt volker testified that he failed to
connect those dots this summer had I
done so I would have raised my own
objections still neither he nor Tim
Morrison seem to think the pressure
campaign on Ukraine qualified as an
impeachable offense did either of you
ever have any evidence of quid pro quo
miss Morrison no ma'am a master volker I
did not any evidence of bribery no ma'am
both were witnesses requested by the
Republicans though their testimony may
not have been the exoneration the GOP
hoped you would agree right that asking
a foreign government to investigate a
domestic political rival is
inappropriate would you not it's not
what was on what we recommended the
president discuss Morrison testified
that he alerted White House lawyers
about president Trump's July call with
his Ukrainian counterpart lieutenant
colonel
sandrov Inman said he went to the
lawyers about the call - it was
inappropriate
during ven-ven's testimony the official
White House Twitter account went after
his judgement anticipating attacks on
his character the combat veteran spoke
directly to his father who he said
worried about the risks his son was
taking you made the right decision 40
years ago to leave the Soviet Union come
here to the United States of America in
search of a better life for our family
do not worry I will be fine for telling
the truth
Benjamin described a White House meeting
with top Ukrainians where Gordon
Sandland the US ambassador to the
European Union told them they needed to
look into the Biden's to get what they
wanted ambassador Sandlin said that in
order to get a White House meeting there
Ukrainians would have to provide a
deliverable which is investigations
Sandland has a lot to explain today he
initially told lawmakers that he didn't
even know that millions in military aid
were being held specifically to
investigate the Biden's
only to later admit that other witnesses
had refreshed his recollection and that
he did tell the Ukrainians that the
resumption of US aid would likely not
occur until Ukraine provided the public
Anti Corruption statement multiple
witnesses say Sandland was actually the
president's point person pushing the
Ukrainians and then reporting back you
also testified that ambassador sunland
had told you on another occasion that he
could call the president whenever he
wanted is that right yes
here's what Democrats will be trying to
get at today how often did the president
directly tell ambassador Sandlin to
pressure the Ukrainians that is going to
be key to the case they're trying to
build that mr. Trump put his personal
interests ahead of national security and
tried to use Ukraine to do it Tony
Nancy thank you very much